Mark: Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and I'm here once again with Wade!
Mark: Hi Wade, how ya doin'?
Wade: Heeey
Mark: It was a scary night!
Both: It was--
Mark: It was a really scary night
Here are some of the noises we heard last night
*Weird noise from Wade*
Not that pleasant one
Mark: Oh Wade you don't need to reenact it
Mark: I have the technology...
Wade: Oh that's right we have footage
*both laugh*
Mark (while laughing): I have the technology t- I've beeen recording this whole time
Mark: I even got those dirty things you said - like this
*weird wild Wade noises*
Mark: No Wade God Stop it *laughter*
*Incoherent stuttering*
Mark: I was gonna cut your words together to make something terrible
Wade: Oh haha
Mark: Okay. Anybody uh Anyway what our plan uh for this round is
Mark: I'm gonna try to increase my view distance because I can't see shit
Mark: But what we're gonna do is we're gonna go north to the forest
Mark: Because its way to hot here in the desert *only when you're there ;)*
Mark: Um and we're overheating which means that we're consuming more water
Mark: Did you know you get iron from hitting a rock?
Wade: No? But I guess that's not too surpri- a lot of games have that kind of feature
Mark: Woah. You get IRON from hitting ROCK! (No way x'D)
Mark: Ok but either way we need to sprint north-west. Wade are you with me?
Wade: I'm a little bit ahead probably.
Wade: You stopped at the rock I kept going
Mark: Oh shit. Oh ok sorry
Mark: I was just enamored by the rock and I'm imagining that the reason you were feeling so wet is because
Mark: the cooling vapors of the forest felt so good on you skin (Yeah lets go with that :) )
Wade: Yes they must feel very- why am I smelling. what does my nose mean
Mark: *sniff* *yandere-plier voice* that smells so good. Maybe you got allergies and you just can't be in the forest
Wade: yeah but. great
Mark: You're like some, some horrible survivor you are
Mark: You can't- You have allergies nyeh heh heh~
Mark: Ok
Wade: *quietly* my only weakness.
Wade: Wait, thats not you. There you are. That was a zombie I was gonna follow
Mark: Oh don't do that. Don't do that at all
Mark: Ok
Mark: I need um it's only getting hotter over here. that's weird.
Wade: well it is becoming further into the day. I don't know maybe it's just
Wade: hot on this map
Mark:  Maybe it is. oop that's a zombo
Mark: Ooh
Wade: Yup
-weird 1 second silence-
Wade: Good thing I followed you right to it
Mark: Yup you're welcome buddy I'm here to help you
Wade: Oh hey why are you beating the rock lady?
Mark: Why is she beating the OH NO SHE'S TRYIN TO BUILD A BASE TOO
Mark and Wade: STOP HER
Mark: SHE'S CRAZY
Wade: I cou- she's a decayed mother
Mark: Oh no
Wade: She's just trying to get rock for her babies
Mark: Is that really what her name was?
Wade: *laughing* Yes
Mark: *slightly horrified* Oh my god
Mark: How does anyone know it's a decayed mother?
Mark: that doesn't make any sense
Wade: I'm so sorry- Oh now she's no longer that she turned
Mark: Ah! fucking criminy
Mark: God this thing snuck up on me
Mark: Search departed woman
Mark: Oh she had a pistol! Ohup she had a pistol!
Wade: Nice! What kind of ammo does it take cause I've got bullets.
Mark: 9 millimeter
Wade: I might have some of that let me look
*Oddly satisfying clicking sounds*
Mark: Alright. Ok.
Wade: where are you? I'm in the middle of of all the rocks
Mark: Alright let me reload this. Oh it came with uh 15 bullets in the chamber and 2 extra bullets
Wade: I've got 3 for ya
Mark: Nice, I'll take em
Wade: Alright well whenever you come back I'll give em to ya
Mark: Where are you
Wade: oh there you are
Mark: Ok so I've got a buttload of wood frames coming
Mark: I've got 30 right now
Mark:  and mor- more on the way
Wade: There right here in front of me but you can't see them
Mark: Wow I- Ohup wait I got em. Ok I got em
Mark: Wow that was tiny
Wade: Yeah
Mark: Ok 90 degrees i think we can work with this it is getting cooler
Mark: Ok so these wood frames. How do we want to build this house?
Wade: Um I don't know just we can start off with somethin' small like one room
Wade: and then just expand it as we get time
Mark: Ok then make a door
Mark: I'll just start putting down framework
Wade: Ok I'm crafting 10 wood frames then I'll make a door
Mark: Ok I'm getting- I'm just getting
Mark: *quietly* fuckin' here we go
Wade: well we can still run back to the other house if we need to for one more night
Mark: I think we'll be ok
Wade: What is- Oh god I thought that was a chainsaw
Mark: Ope
Mark: *chuckles*
Mark: I'm telling you Dead by Daylight
Mark: Ooh that's really close. I-I can get that
Mark: I can get that
Mark: It's right nearby
Mark: I'll be back baby. Wow, why did it get brighter?
Wade: I don't-
Wade: -know but I was able to build in that little hole you dug so good job
Mark: *very shrill* YAAAAY!
Wade: there's like ok there's three. I think i can handle three
Mark: Uhh do you have bows and arrows?
Wade: Oh no they stung me
Mark: Don't do that. don't- are you trapped in the house
Wade: No
Mark: Don't... Wade...
Mark: Don't die. Don't die
Wade: I'm out of the house
Mark: I mean our bed rolls are literally right in the desert
Wade: Oh go away. Die, I hate you!
Mark: Don't die Wade
Mark: *whispers* Wade don't do it, please
Mark: We need you
Mark: I came- I got here right as it landed
Wade: Oh god. this one is so, chunky
Wade: AHHH
Mark: NOOOO!
Mark:Wade, No.
Wade: The big one is so hard to kill
Mark: Waaddee. Wade Noo.
Mark: I'm gonna make arrows and come back. you just spawned at the thing right?
Mark: Oh shit I don't have enough feathers, Iva- I haven't been looking for nests
Mark: what?
Wade: I need to use the bow and arrow
Mark: You hit R to reload it
Mark: To start it and then you right click to look in
Wade: I don't have any arrows cause they were on my body that died
Mark: *profoundly* Oh no.
Wade: Is there a take all option
Mark: Uhh, I don't know but watch out for this guy.
Mark: I'm shootin' him
*bow noises* *zombie groans*
Mark: Oh he's tough
*more bow noises* *more zombie groans*
Mark: Where did these guys come from?
Wade: Ahh
Wade: They just wandered up- ok he's dead.
Mark: K...He's got an old sham sandwich that we don't need.
Mark: We need storage also
Wade: There were two more-
Wade: Uh zombies.
Mark: I killed a nurse
Wade: Yeah
Mark: And that guy
Wade: Ok there was one more I'm not sure where she went then
Mark: I don't hear her so I'm assuming everything's ok.
Wade: I guess she must have wondered off.
Mark: I'm gonna let my guard down
Wade: Is there a take all. Is 'R' take all
Mark: 'Cuz everything is probably fine
Wade: Yes it is. Ok
Mark: Oh, it's getting late and we don't have proper defenses
Mark: Do we have a door?
Wade: Ya
Mark: Ok good *nervous laughter*
Wade: I put one on there
Mark: Wade I'm so scared
Wade: Yeah
Mark: I want to build a campfire in the middle of our house
Mark: What does it matter if your skill in construction is up?
Wade: Maybe you build faster? Maybe it takes less resources? I don't know.
Mark: That could be. Oh I seem to be chopping the wood down a little faster I guess
Wade: What? Oh I'm just- I'm just now level two
Mark: Yaaayy! You did it. You did it
Wade: Yay I-
Mark: I'm probably dying of hunger by the way
Wade: That's the sound of not having any wood. that ding ding ding. that was weird
Mark: D'ok
Wade: Do you hear that whenever you try to build with no wood. like it makes a weird dingy noise
Mark: No
Wade: Oh
Wade: Maybe it's just me then
Mark: I think it is
Mark: Ok
Mark: Craft- what-what happened to my stone?!
Mark: I had stone. What the fuck happened to my stone? I had lots of stone.
Wade: It's so late
Mark: Oh god
Mark: We're so dead
Mark: It's fine I just need stone but-
Mark: Uh yeah I'm at 25% hunger
Mark: Geezums
Wade: I've got a full pie I can give you
Mark: Do you need it more?
Wade: No. I don't think so
Mark: Ok
Mark: Coming in.
Mark: Oh that's right, I spent all my stone on uh
Wade: There you go
Wade: There's a full pie on the ground right there
Mark: Thanks
Wade: It looks real small in front of me
Mark: Thank ya baby
Mark: Ok hang on
Wade: Don't forget that pie
Mark: Woah
Mark: Meat stew?
*No! It's a pie Mark! Don't you listen!?*
Wade: Yup
Mark: Oh shit my inventory's full let me put this campfire down
Mark: Hang on. In the corner here. Boink
Mark: *more enthusiastic* Boink
Mark: Ok and then meat pie
Mark: Eat dat pie
Mark: Eat it up. MMMmm. It's a meat stew.
Mark: Ok
Mark: Whoo
Mark: I think, we'll be fine if there's no roof right?
Wade: I think so. I'm gonna build up one more layer
Mark: Ok. Oh boy.
Wade: the corners first because the corners you cant-
Wade: there you go
Mark: You can't forget. they still walk through the corners?
Mark: Is that still a thing?
Wade: I don't know but I know if I don't get the corner blocks now
Wade: I can't build them while we're inside I gotta go outside to get them.
Mark: Ok alright. Umm good news oops
Mark: Good news, umm when I dug in the dirt I got fertile dirt so what I need to do is
Mark: I just need to go and get more dirt
Mark: And then I can plant this corn
Mark: and everything will be hunkey dory
Mark: It'll be great
Mark: Trust me, trust me
Wade: I really hope there's nothing that like flies and attacks you
Mark: *high pitched* What?
Mark: That's- that's absurd
Wade: There used to- like way back when there used to be. I don't know if they took that out or not
Mark: Ok I planted corn
Wade: Good, good
Mark: I- I hope it'll do good, I hope nothing stops it
*Unsure mmmmmm-ing*
Mark: There really used to be things that fly? I don't, I don't like that
Wade: Yeah like a LONG time ago
Mark: *quietly* I- I don't like that
Wade: How many wood blocks do you have right now
Mark: Ahh, these will be the- thats the last one
Wade: I'll start hammering the ones you placed
Wade: I'll do what I can with what I've got left
Mark: I've got a sniper riffle barrel and an SMG stock but no actual things
Wade: I've got shotgun parts but
Mark: Yeah
Mark: We need like uhh we need uhh we need like a storage box
Wade: Oh hold E on it and you can do different things
Mark: I'm gonna put cloth in there, this baseball cap, barrel thing, cotton, fertile dirt, bowl casing
Mark: Uh this spare iron, brass, nitrate powder, lead, military fiber, pine seed,
Mark: Uhhhh, this murky water until we know what to do with it, a rocket launcher stock, leather duster
Mark: Coffee beans, (Wade: Jesus...) warm boots. I had a lot of stuff, ok I had a lot of stuff
Wade: I see that
Mark: Yeah um the only thing that we need though is we need A POT!
Mark: How do we make a god damn pot?
Mark: Ugh
Mark: There is no pot in this recipe, there is nothing.
Mark: Maybe it's just something you find.
Wade: It might be we might just have to go into a- keep searching around until we find one
Mark: Ok
Mark: Oh boy
Wade: And it's night time
Mark: Ok well I'll crouch down
Mark: And we'll just never speak of anything ever again
Wade: Sounds- Sounds like the right way to go about it
Mark: Yup
Mark: *whispers* It's so dark wade
Wade: Yeah it is
Mark: What do we do?
Mark: Wade don't do that, that's a terrible idea why do you have rolled up newspapers on your arms?
*giggles*
Wade: My armor
Mark: You literally have duct tape wrapped newspaper on your arms
Mark: Your whole arm- you've got newspaper on your legs
Wade: It protects me?
Mark: Wade you look like the craziest old man in the wasteland
Mark: Apparently if you just press R it will take all and close it
Wade: I got it
Wade: I got a deer
Mark: Yay!
Wade: How do I?
Mark: I found a lead- I found a pipe. I found a lead rod, err an iron rod
Mark: Whatever you know what I meant
Wade: Oh the iron pipe
Mark: Yeah iron pipe that was it
Mark: All the things that I said that were wrong, yeah that
Mark: That thing
Wade: Yeah
Wade: Ok so whenever you kill an animal you got to like use your like hatchet or something to gather it I guess
Mark: Well that makes sense that's from rust you got to like whump it really hard.
Wade: Two animal fat, 3 raw meat, 4 hide
Mark: Come on rabbit, I'm gonna kill this rabbit
Wade: How far am I from home
Wade: Aww I still don't have a- wait I need to put a bed roll down so i can see where our home is
Mark: Yes killed the rabbit
Mark: KILL DA WABBIT
Mark: Kill da wabbit
Wade: Can you fill empty jars up?
Wade: In the rain? that'd be cool
Mark: Umm I've got tons of jars of murky water but are you talking like for fresh water?
Wade: Yeah
Mark: Well that I don't know. Oh boy I'm overheating.
Mark: That ain't good
Wade: Oh really?
Mark: Yeah
Wade: A blood bag?
Mark: A blood bag?
Wade: Got that from one of the nurses
Wade: I keep killing the nurses in the hopes that they'll like give us like antibiotics and medicine and stuff
Mark: Yeah that's good call
Mark: Yeah this air drop must have dropped right in the middle of the ocean
Mark:  because I'm not loading up anything beyond water
Mark: Like as far around as I go
Wade: I didn't know there was an ocean
Mark: Uhh it's big it's just a lake I imagine but even so
Mark: K I haven't found a pot dammit
Mark: This is, not going well brotha
Mark: It's not going good, ahh I struck out dude
Mark: I struck out hard
Mark: I got a lot of stuff, I got some meat I got some animal hide but no pot to cook it in
Mark: I can't believe that you'd have to craft, you'd have to scaveng- oooh
Mark: What
Wade: The thunder
Mark: Oh
Wade: I ran out of arrows at a bad time, its the guy who killed me last time.
Mark: I'm comin'
Mark: I'm comin' back
Wade: Come on seriously?
Mark: What was that other,
Mark: There was another *constipated GoatWade noise* Mark: Nah, its far away
Wade: HAGH
Wade: My club broke too. At a bad time..
Mark: Woo, almost ran into a Zombo
Mark: So I gotta get back, and I gotta put this meat in a locker before-
Mark: Before zombies get a REAL sniff of it
Wade: Oh wait, I'm bleeding out
Wade: NOO
Mark: How're you bleeding out?!
Mark: OHH god dammit! Wade no..
Mark: How many times have you died now?
Wade: Twooo..
Mark: Uh- Count the other times...
Wade: Seven
Mark: Yeah, that's what I thought.
Wade: Twooo...
Wade: Oh god! I gotta spawn in the desert too!
Mark: Oh geez. There was something there that was like...
Mark: Geez... There was something...
Mark: Cra-Crawly. There was a crawly dude in our house!
Wade: Oh... Probably because we didn't build a floor. They can probably spawn in there. That's scary...
Mark: Oh, Thats no good. Im- Im putting the meat in there.
Mark: Animal hide...
Mark: Uhhhhhh... Skull cap, warm murky water...
Mark: A human turd! I have a human turd.
Mark: Why do I have a human turd?
Wade: I don't know
Mark: Woooo....
Wade: My bag is just North-East of the camp. I wonder how long how long it would stay there?
*Thunder or lightning*
Mark: Oh geez. God Damn...
Wade: Now you hear it!
Mark: WOW
Wade: See! It's scary!
Mark: That is INTENSE!
Wade: Yes it is.
Mark: Holy Shit!
Mark: What food po- If you eat an egg... *Sigh*
Mark: If you eat an egg raw, you get food poisoning
Wade: What does that do? Lower your health?
Mark: I don't know. It just says food poisoning 100%!
Wade: Great.
Mark: Whatever it is, it can't be good...
Wade: I think we should hang out here for the night and go for my body tomorrow...
Mark: Yeah. There's nothing- boiled egg..
Mark: You have FOOD?
Wade: I have Sham sandwiches
Mark: Yay! Those will get food poisoning!
Wade: You're on- They're on that chest there
Mark: Why do I- Why- Why do I want to eat those?
Wade: 'Cuz they're all we've got
Mark: Uhhh...Wait, was my chest the left one?
Wade: Yeah
Mark: Oh whoops I dumped things in the right one. I am a fool!
Mark: I'm eating it! Nom nom nom nom nom, food poisoning! Yes yes yes!
Wade: What time is it officially night? 20?
Mark: Like, 21.
Wade: *Muttered 'oh great', complete with a sigh*
Wade: I- I don't have time to make it to my body and back then, do I?
Mark: Okay so food poisoning apparently just effects stamina - really badly
Mark: So I guess you could eat it at night,
And you'd generally still be okay
Mark: Oh yeah! Food poisoning- It's only lasting 10 seconds
Wade: Oh, okay good. Good good...
Mark: Oh yeah,
So I'm gonna put eggs in my chest and you can take them
Wade: Can we cook the eggs, or do we need something to cook them in?
Mark: Yeah, I looked. You can cook without like, putting in a recipe
You need water to make boiled eggs so that would be the cooked version
Wade: It would be cool if we made like a water catcher. It rains so much
Mark: Oh! No, wait!
I can make bacon and eggs
Oooh, I can make bacon and eggs
Cuz if I take this raw meat...
Wade: You don't need like a skillet or pot or a pan or anything?
Mark: Ugh, you do. Okay, you do. Goddammit you do
You need like a grill - oh shit you need so much stuff
Wade: Bellows. We need a bellows. What did you say we need to make that?
Mark: Animal hide, like 20 of em, a lot of em...
Wake: Okay so we need to kill a bunch of animals...
Mark: Oh it's snowing!
Mark: Oooooh!
Wade: Snowing?
Mark: OOH!
Mark: Whoa hello snow on the ground. That's weird
-I didn't know that was a thing in this biome
Mark: Apparently it is now. Hurray! It's a Christmas miracle! *Zombie groaning in agreement*
Wade: I'm so glad we have a floor and a roof to keep us warm
Mark: Yeaaahhhh
Mark: Okay but if you- if you need food real bad there's raw meat and there's...
*Groaning zombie: Um yes I would like some food tyvm*
Mark: Murky water *muttering* I wonder what dysentery does for ya
*Zombie: SHARE UR FOOD WITH ME!!*
*At the same time*
Mark: In this situation
Wade: I'm fine right now
Mark: Cuz there's TONS of murky water in your chest
Wade: Oh, uh be careful about making noise. There's a horde coming by - I hear them
Mark: Oh boy. I'm undetected
Mark: Sensed! Oh shit, what does that mean?!
Undetected okay it's fine
*The zombie has given up on Mark and Wade...for now*
Mark: Sensed, undetected, what does that mean?
*Zombie wanders off to share tales of Youtubers who wouldn't share their food*
Mark: Okay I'm drinking uh
Some water... *Thunder booming*
Murky water...
Wade: Well the snow came and went pretty quick didn't it?
Mark: Well there we have- there we go then
Mark: It keeps flittering in between sensed and unsensed
Mark: That's very disconcerting
Mark: Maybe I need to turn off the fire...
Mark: Turn off. There we go
Mark: Okay
Mark: Undetected.
Mark: Alright, we're good. Alright it's cool
Wade: Alright
Mark: *Stuttering* I- I- I just pooped again
Wade: Oh, I've not pooped yet I don't think
Mark: I am pooping so much - probably because I have dysentery. Dysentery lasts for 40 minutes. Good god
Mark: That's not good
Wade: Is that from the murky water?
Mark: Yeah :/
Mark: And I think it just effects your stamina recovery because it's a little slower
Mark: And I might be losing a tiny bit of health
Wade: Huh.
Mark: But it's better than- *sigh*
Wade: Being me with only 76 of everything
Mark: Yeah...
*Sigh*
Wade: Oh, we're gonna need a second iron pipe
Mark: Oh, for what?
Wade: To make the bellows
Mark: Oh, dammit! I've got- wait I've got two!
Mark: I've got short iron pipes. I'm gonna put 'em in yours
Boink!
Mark: Okay! :)
Wade: Got iron pipe for that and the bellows
Wade: Where was the bellows...
Wade: Yeah, yeah! Two short iron pipes, cool!
Mark: It's in your storage
Wade *same time*: Okay
Wade: Awesome. So we just need to get a bunch of animal hide
Mark: And lumps of clay
Wade: Lumps of clay...
Mark: Okay! We'll figure that out in the next episode!
Wade: Yes!
Mark: Let us know what you think of the series
if you wanna see more let us know
We're surviving pretty good in the new version of 7 Days to Die
But it's really difficult
This is- this is HARD
Wade: Yeah it is
Mark *Muttering*: No joke
Wade: It's- I told you it was a lot harder
Mark: Yeah. But anyway, thank you guys so much,
check out Wade's channel in the description below and thanks again
And as always, we'll see you...
in the next video...
BYE-BYE!